bonjour et les coquerelles merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous et d'être
notre invité politique ce matin on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes vous êtes
député de la france insoumise l'heureuse
idée de la france un semis de la
seine-saint-denis auteurs de ce livre là
chez nous la dette c'est aux éditions de
l'atelier et je le disais on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représente et
manadja la mer bonjour pascal du groupe
et moi les journaux régionaux de l'est
de la france on commence bien évidemment
eric coquerel par la crise sanitaire et
ce texte vigilance sanitaire examiné ce
matin par les députés les sénateurs eux
il l'examiné hier l'examen tourné court
ils ont rejeté avant même l'examen sur
le fond parce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord sur la date avec le
gouvernement et donc avec la majorité à
l'assemblée il voulait un pass and it
est inquiet jusqu'au 28 février le
gouvernement veut jusqu'au 31 juillet ce
qui sera acté ce matin selon toute
vraisemblance et la victoire du
gouvernement sur ce texte
parlé clairement en tout cas c'est la
victoire des modèles macron mairie
craques parce que je vous fais remarquer
une chose c'est combien d'associations
ça passe de très peu à l'assemblée la
fois c'était une quinzaine de voix
d'écart alors que les maquereaux nice
ont eu bien plus large majorité et que
si on fait le cumul entre l'assemblée et
le parlement deux tiers en réalité des
parlementaires ce sera opposé à ce texte
moi je crois qu'il faut pas passer en
force comme ça je fasse à une épidémie
il faut chercher l'unité bon et l'unité
il faut aussi chercher des compromis
avec les oppositions ce gouvernement a
une caractéristique
nous nous pensons que la prolongation du
passani terre est dangereux pour la
liberté s'impose une société de
surveillance ça donne lui aussi il faut
sécurité
par exemple c'est à dire installer le
passé à l'inter mais d'un autre côté
rendent et est payant alors même qu'il
faut continuer à détecter les gens au
contraire ou par exemple laisser penser
qu'avec le pass and it erp vous pouvez
finalement abaisser le masque dans des
lieux des lieux fermés alors qu'on sait
que si le vaccin est absolument précieux
pour lutter contre la maladie mais ils
n'assurent pas une garantie totale
contre la non transmission donc je
trouve que d'un côté il ya y avait des
signaux mauvais qu'ils sont faits on
parlera peut-être de l'hôpital tout à
l'heure sur l' île à l'autre côté on
prend des mesures et jusqu'en juillet or
le goût par exemple aurait pu au moins
accepter que on se revoit en février
c'est à dire qu'on respecte les droits
du parlement même ça il n'a pas failli
passe en france qu'est-ce qui les
expliquent pour vous les sénateurs de la
majorité disent qu'il ya une volonté du
gouvernement de ne pas avoir ce débat à
six mois de la présidentielle qui
pourraient nuire à emmanuel macron vous
partager ce point de vue enfin mon
problème d'épanouir emmanuel macron le
problème c'est de respecter le parlement
le parlement c'est pas juste une
instance il ya une ministre le jour
freaks et bourillon qui nous dit mais
vous inquiétez pas il ya les questions
au gouvernement il ya des rapports et
c'est facile et c'est pas ça le
parlement au vote donc imaginez que vous
prolongez impasse annie terre que du
coup vous banalisez parce que quand on
pense qu'on peut comme ça le prolonger
enfin en tout cas on peut laisser au
gouvernement le soin de décider si on
revient au couvre-feu
si on vient au confinement survient pas
sanitaire jusqu'en juillet prochain
c'est le banaliser et le parlement est
là pour dessiner donc bon bah on est on
est dans le maquereau nice pure qui
utilisent la vème république en réalité
pour prendre ses décisions sol et je
regrette que mes collègues de la
majorité ne se rendent même pas compte
qu'ils ont quand même un mandat qui lors
qu'il est quelque part les oblige
vis-à-vis de leurs électeurs bien à
prendre des décisions dans ce pays
manifestement il s'est plutôt de 70 des
sillons paillasson est ce que la
question se pose maintenant de la
troisième dose est ce qu'il faut
conditionner se passe année terre à la
troisième dose le gouvernement réfléchit
pour vous et va le faire on y va bien et
vous avez raison de tickets ça parce que
la question lui a été posée et troisième
dose c'est pas rien ça veut dire que
vous commencez en réalité à imaginer un
pass sanitaire permanente c'est-à-dire
que troisièmes jo ça voudrait dire
qu'elle n'aura une quatrième et donc on
est en train d'installer un pass
sanitaire qui est la manne en pouvant
passer sa scission si on inclut l'idée
que dans le passé a dit être la
troisième dose on aura bientôt la 4e et
vous et donc on est en train d'installer
une société qui face à une épidémie qui
va durer est ce que le choix oui oui oui
on a le choix je pense d'abord je vous
fais remarquer une chose c'est que le
pass sanitaire est installé en france et
tout le monde nous dit que l'épidémie va
redémarrer donc vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas une garantie absolue moi je
pense que le choix c'est de mettre le
paquet alors conduit à mettre le paquet
sur les vaccins mais en allant persuader
les gens convaincre les gens je crois
pas l'obligation excellent mais
convaincre les gens chercher une voie
médicamenteuse
là dessus on est très en retard et puis
mettre le paquet sur les hôpitaux sur
les hôpitaux ce qui n'a pas été fait
parce qu'à chaque fois le problème il
est il est quoi il est que la capacité
des hôpitaux au craint qu'elles soient
dépassées et là on n'en dit pas là on va
parler de l'hôpital évidemment dans
quelques secondes mais d'abord un mot
puisqu'il ya des salariés qui sont
suspendus puisqu'ils n'ont pas se passe
sanitaire donc faute de vaccination
quinze présidents de départements
socialistes ont écrit au premier
ministre puisque le gouvernement veut
que ces salariés deviennent éligibles au
rsa les présidents de départements
socialistes s'y opposent vous comprenez
leur position alors la position de dire
que c'est pas au rsa de compenser le
salaire de ces personnes oui la position
mais alors on sait pas trop si c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit au final parce que moi je
les ai interpellé j'ai notamment
interpeller le président du conseil
général de seine saint denis bon j'ai
pas bien compris si finalement ils
avaient dit qu'ils ne verseraient pas le
rsa bon mais en tout cas il faut aussi
s'il vous verrez on décide qu'il faut
verser le rsa on va pas ajouté une
double peine aux gens qui déjà ont été
suspendus
parmi ces suspendu il ya des gens qui
sont des callunes impayés et que du coup
ça a créé une égalité avec le problème
c'est qu'ils soient suspendus premier
problème de ça c'est le gouvernement a
fait quand même canton et soignants on
est là pour protéger les autres dont
l'axé soignant le soin ne savent pas
vous croyez qu'ils on a su bien sûr que
ça mais ils ont déjà des obligations oui
mais vaccinale vous pourquoi refuser
celle là fait quand on signe aussi
adroit répondent et les soignants ils
ont été à la pointe du combat pendant
deux ans ils ont été mon protégé puisque
le gouvernement elle n'avait même pas
trouvé le moyen de leur donner les blues
les masques vision it mêmes choses
rappelle monsieur vers en conseillant
aux soignants d'y aller avant la fin de
leur période de protection enfin quand
ils étaient contaminés vision était et
que je sache quand je regarde dans les
hôpitaux les soignants ils savent se
protéger alors imaginer un système où
ceux qui ont été des héros voulait
pointé comme les responsables d'une
possible contamination les obligations à
vacciner pire en les suspendant alors
manquons de soignants partout on va y
revenir tout à l'heure je trouve que
c'est à la fois stupide et c'est
indécent ou je suis contre le fait de
donner des sanctions à des salariés
parce qu'ils ne sont pas vaccinés alors
que le vaccin n'est pas obligatoire
voilà c'est ainsi
je l'assumé je ne suis pas d'accord avec
cette vision des choses est par contre
le fait de les priver d'allocations
chômage je trouve ça encore plus
scandaleux le fait de les renvoyer au
rsa c'est pas la bonne solution mais du
côté de ceux qui versent ou pas le rsa
dans les départements
bon bah si c'est la seule solution faut
le faire tout en contestant au
gouvernement le fait qu'ils ont emprunté
cette voie là et on va parler de
l'hôpital bien évidemment puisque vous
le rappeliez à 20% actuellement de lits
d'hôpitaux qui sont fermés faute de
soigner en tout cas c'est le chiffre de
jean françois delfraissy les sénateurs
aient l'air ils vont lancer une
commission d' enquête sur ce sujet pour
faire la lumière et pour voir comment on
peut résoudre ce problème vous les
soutenez là dessus on le fait dans l'eau
de rue et bien sûr le fait de faire une
commission d'enquêté oui bon je pense
que les commissions dans lequel il va
falloir qu'ils enquêtent aussi sur les
agissements du parc fable l'ex parti
républicain dans le temps parce que
pendant que la loi bachelot elle y est
pour quelque chose dans cet état
d'esprit dont jean castex de la
responsabilité partagée a la
responsabilité
depuis une trentaine d'années maintenant
se partagent le pouvoir dans ce pays ce
qui n'est pas notre cas et notamment qui
ont institué en même temps je veux quand
mélenchon
met d'accord il ya 30 ou vernis à 30 ans
on est on est on n'avait pas encore
décidé de l'andam et la loi bachelot le
rappel qui ont quand même aggraver les
choses le lait les quels sont les
problèmes qui nous sont posées c'est que
pendant très longtemps dans ce pays on a
défini les besoins en matière de santé
par exemple on estime que aujourd'hui il
faut 4 % de plus d'augmentation
ddd des moyens pour faire face aux
besoins en termes de population donc au
et puis on cherchait andy barron
d'augmenter un peu la cotisation au met
home est l argent etc et puis à partir
de l'ondam la fin des années 90 on a
changé la logique on a dit on définit un
budget et on adapte les besoins ce
budget ça a été le premier gros problème
deuxième problème c'est la loi bachelot
qui carrément à faire entrer des
critères d'entreprise dans les hôpitaux
là où évidemment chacun comprendra que
c'est pas ça qui est de mise parce que
le quoi qu'il en coûte pour la santé
maintenant je pense que tout le monde
l'a admis la santé comme le bien le plus
précieux donc il faut re détricoter tout
ça et c'est parce que fait le
gouvernement aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le
gouvernement depuis 2010 est c'est moins
4 milliards pour les hôpitaux encore
cette année encore cette année il va y
avoir par rapport au nombre
d'augmentations la population des moyens
il y aura encore une baisse en réalité
des moyens donnés à l'hôpital donc
structuré le moigne ahmad mariés à des
investissements qui sont faits sur la
ligne à des augmentations pour les
soignants alors là les augmentations
prix soignants sont insuffisants par un
ou par au retard pris jours rappelle qu'
insuffisant mais oui d'accord mais même
avec le ségur on est au 18e rang dans l'
ocde sur le les rémunérations des
soignants et les soignants ou pas
demander des primes le fait d'être
valorisés en terme de salaire pour ça
c'est le premier problème deuxième
problème effectivement il ya eu un
numerus clausus qui a était inapte
dessily thé pendant des années mais le
troisième problème quand on vous dit
qu'il ya des investissements moi je vous
dis on continue à fermer des lits
d'hôpitaux dans ce pays pendant la crise
- 5800 fermeture de lui en 2020 on
continue on envisager moi j'ai pendant
dans ma circonscription
on imagine la construction d'un hôpital
à saint-ouen qui va remplacer bichat et
beaujon moins 360 lits par rapport aux
deux hôpitaux précédent c'est drôle à
faire mais bien sûr il faut un moratoire
tout de suite afin de lui faire notre
sol y est il faut arrêter année après
année appauvrir l'hôpital et la santé
publique française canton pour ouvrir
des lits faut mettre du personnel a en
face est aujourd'hui bien dans les
écoles d'infirmières un tiers
démissionne tiendront pour avoir lors
pourquoi votre avis parce que les
horaires des caps pour plusieurs raisons
évidemment il ya ce que vous dites là
tension les salaires insuffisants mais
il ya aussi bien des métiers qui
n'attire plus il n'y a pas de
télétravail il ya des horaires décalés
il ya des week-ends c'est aussi parce
que c'est qu'ils ne sont pas assez
valorisé par les salaires déjà oui ça
fait partie blanc il n'y a pas que ça on
est sûr les générations qui n'ont
peut-être pas non moi je crois par
contre je ne crois pas ça je crois pas à
ça moi j'ai été voir que tu es on sait
très bien pendant que vides si l'hôpital
a tenu quand même malgré tout c'est sur
la qualité des soignants et des gens
sans personnages restent donc je crois
pas à cette histoire je crois qu'à un
moment donné quand même vous atteignez
le but quand par exemple du fait qu' on
n'a pas créé assez libre personnel je
prends l'hôpital delafontaine à
saint-denis on demande au personnel qui
est en en en pédiatrie c'est-à-dire qui
soigne les petits enfants de tout d'un
coup faire du soin palliatif pour les
personnes atteintes qu'ovide ils le font
ils l'ont fait mais vous rend vous
imaginez le traumatisme pour des gens
qui sont là pour soigner les bébés et
qui se retrouvent à accompagner en fin
de vie des personnes plutôt âgées en non
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que là
ça a été la le le sujet trop bon et que
du coup il ya plein de gens qui sont
alors qu'est ce qu'il fallait faire par
rapport à ça pour les rassurer il
fallait effectivement dire qu'on allait
mettre le paquet en terme d'embauchés
qu'on allait arrêter avec cette gestion
stupide des hôpitaux qui la gestion
managériale où on met les critères
d'entreprise et qu'on allait revaloriser
beaucoup plus les revenus c'est pas ce
qui a été fait et pas suffisamment un
dernier mot sur ces questions de santé
rivés vers en a commandé un rapport sur
l'avenir du système de soins
l'articulation entre assurance maladie
et complémentaires santé parmi les
hypothèses celle d'une grande sécu au
détriment des mutuelles c'est une idée
vous soutiendriez ça oui c'est possible
c'est possible je pense que nous on est
pour le remboursement 100% sait qu on
l'avait déjà aux programmes je sais bien
que peut-être que les mutuelles vont
vont protester mais je crois que c'est
serait nécessaire on est on a trop au
fil des ans installé un système où la
sécurité sociale devient presque plus le
complément des mutuellement avec les
avec l'impossibilité pour certains d'y
recourir donc moi je nous on est pour le
100 % sécurité même si les mutuelles les
entreprises à porte à porte leur part
gagner bien sûr mais vous me demandez
comme vous et moi je préférais que les
entreprises et les salariés des
mutuelles et bien quelque part soit
versé sur un grand système parce qu'ils
avaient toujours du travail sur un grand
système de sécurité sociale qui assure
le 100% sécurité sociale du budget
puisque la dpt elle examine en ce moment
même ce budget hier l'assemblée
nationale a voté le fameux contrat
engagement jeunes qui a été annoncé par
emmanuel macron il ya quelques jours
jusqu'à 500 euros pour les jeunes c'est
une bonne mesure ce contrat pour vous
c'est vraiment de l'esbrouffe quoi si
tous macron voilà à un moment donné il
ay là il appelle un revenu d'engagement
pour les jeunes archers chez les jeunes
qui n'osent tourner ça se dit bah tiens
on va voir un rose lui tous les jeunes
c'est ça qui se traduisent un puisque
nous parlons d pour le rsa jeunes
l'allocation d'étude ils ont dû traduire
un peu ça et à la fin du fin on arrive à
quoi on arrive à recycler des déchets
chose qui existe parce que le lors d'une
longue le contrat d'engagement ce n'est
rien d'autre que la garantie jeunes
aujourd'hui qui existe à peu près pour
les mêmes les mêmes revenus avec un peu
plus de jeunes que ce qui va être prévu
et puis par exemple des solutions à
l'emploi enfin j'ai pu le terme exact
mais vous comprendrez donc on recycle et
se recycle c'est qu'en fait pour cette
histoire de contrat d'engagement dans le
budget il n'y a pas beaucoup d'argent
qui ont été émissaire on va puiser dans
l'argent qui existait donc des gens
recyclent deuxième ans avait concerné
que quatre cent mille jeunes alors que
on pense qu'un au moins plus glam plus
du double qui sont théoriquement
concernés troisièmement ça laisse de
côté les étudiants les sans emploi qui
sont évidemment qu'ils ont besoin
normalement d'une de l'argent pour vivre
donc voilà je trouve que c'est quelque
chose qui va pas résoudre branche qui va
pas résoudre la solution à la situation
mais qui par contre en recycle et qui
permet une juste né fed annonce vous est
il favorable quoi un rsa jeunes oui nous
on est favorable au rsa jeunes on s'y
est prononcée et là on est
quand même
nous le rsa jeunes pour nous c'est au
niveau du du seuil de pauvreté
c'est-à-dire bill 63 euros ce n'est pour
le remonter en u pour sa jeune et donc
pas à 500 euros on est pour une
allocation d'études et non pas pour 500
euros avec dans lequel on vous demande
en échange 20 heures de formation
qualifiante car voilà on pense qu'il
faut aider la jeunesse parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est elle qui souffre le
plus de l'augmentation j'ai bien
l'augmentation tendance qu'on me le
gouvernement de la pauvreté dans ce pays
alors ça c'est pas que le gouvernement
puisque vous en parlez une étude de
l'insee qui révèle que le nombre de
pauvres en france est resté stable en
2020 par rapport à 2010 9 grâce aux
aides exceptionnelles de l'état c'est ce
que dit l'insee versées principalement
aux plus précaires le directeur général
de l'insee dix ans les mesures de l'état
il y aurait eu 400 me pauvres de plus en
2020 est ce que finalement c'est la
preuve que l'état à mener une bonne
politique
oui alors le rapport de l'insee j'ai pas
la phrase exacte mais le rapport de
lycées alerte aussi sur
l'intensification de la pauvreté la
torre des pauvres ou dit aussi oui
d'accès président il n'y a pas plus de
pauvres mais qui sont plus
des bonnes nouvelles notamment sur le
surendettement il faut sont de 8 7 11 %
d'augmentation
de personnes ayant besoin de l'aide
alimentaire c'était un chiffre on avait
donné qu'ils sont des jeunes d'ailleurs
voilà des jeunes et on a 7 % de plus de
rsa ça remonte depuis juillet ce qui est
très inquiétant sur la durée côté qu' on
ait pas eu plus de pauvres
quantitativement qu' il y a deux ans
quand déjà il y avait beaucoup de
pauvres dans ce pays c'est déjà un
problème parce que je vous rappelle que
depuis depuis 2010 est il ya quatre cent
mille personnes en situation de pauvreté
en plus dans ce pays mais qu'en plus on
est mis de côté pour pas les mettre dans
le calcul c'est le calcul jeans et je le
conteste pas mais par contre c'est des
gens qui sont vraiment en situation de
pauvreté les étudiants les sans domicile
et cetera soit à peu près 800 mille
personnes en plus qui fait que nous nous
affirmons il ya plus de 10 millions de
pauvres dans ce pays c'est un problème
c'est à dire que se contenter du fait
qu'ils en avaient beaucoup avant qu'il
en reste beaucoup et la spéculation et
bien moi je me réjouis pas de ça mais
l'intensification un tas de la pauvreté
elle est palpable je vous rappelle que
pendant la crise du coc vide le préfet
de seine-saint-denis avait expliqué qu
on était en risque de famine en cen sad
malheureusement les associations les
collectifs c'est beaucoup aussi acquis
aide on était là on ici de contribuer
mais on est donc on reste dans une
situation absolument catastrophique
quand par ailleurs les 500 plus grandes
fortunes de france ont vu leurs revenus
leur patrimoine doubler en 5 à la hausse
à hocine seddik les aides de l'état que
les aides de l'état pour les plus
pauvres ont posé sur près de 5% de leurs
revenus en 2020 et qu'en proportion des
revenus les 10% les plus pauvres ont été
les plus aidés par les aides du
gouvernement est ce que du coup ça met
pas à mal votre argument d'emmanuel
match 15 ans des riches non c'est pas
vrai ça si je conteste la manière de les
utiliser c'est à dire que on nous a
donné des grands tableaux juste à au
début du projet de loi de finances on
voyait en pourcentage l'augmentation
des revenus alors on avait l'impression
si on disait 12% je crois que c'était 3
% d'augmentation pour les plus pauvres
la barre était très haute et puis du
coup on avait l'impression que pour les
autres finalement c'était possible et
sauf que quand on regarde ce que c'est
que ce que ça ce que savait à quoi ça
correspond au revenu on n'a plus du tout
la même le même tableau parce que chacun
comprendra que si vous augmentez de 5%
un revenu quand vous gagnez 100 mille
euros par mois c'est pas la même chose
que quand vous gagnez 1000 et surtout
regretter ça ne tenait pas compte du
pouvoir parce que quand on tient compte
du pouvoir d'achat la vérité c'est qu'à
22 % de ce qui a été produit en termes
de cadeaux fiscaux en termes de
politique de l'état par le gouvernement
qui ont été aux 10% les plus riches
c'est ça la réalité quand on est riche
dans ce pays on s'est considérablement
enrichie avec emmanuel macron
oui donc un budget qui quand même
compliquée qu'elle dépense vous n'auriez
pas un fait dans ce budget
sachant qu'on a beaucoup dépensé pendant
le coït les 10 millions de baisses
d'impôts de production voilà c'est une
dépense enfin quand vous baisser les
recettes et les dépenses je donne un
exemple
donc voilà c'est c'est une fois de plus
on a
d'autres m'ont soutenu je joue
l'exercice lui ai alors dit % pourquoi
parce que les 10 % d'impôt de production
baisse ça va être à peu près de 940
euros pour chaque tpe et puis 9 millions
pour les très grosses entreprises bon et
tout montre à toutes les études dont la
troisième étude qui a été fait par tran
stratégie pour que cette politique de
mettre de l'argent sont conditions sans
contrepartie en les entreprises ne
nourris ni l'investissement ni les
salaires ni l'emploi
dans les tpe alors les tpe qu'on
s'entende bien nous on est pour aider
les entreprises mais on est pour les
aider sur conditions sûres sur le fait
par exemple de dire qu'une entreprise
qui fait des bénéfices qui licencient
effet des dividendes pardon on n'a pas à
l'idée voilà au plus tôt la version les
choses on doit lui mater de se verser
des dividendes ce qui a fait le cac40 1
51 milliard de dividendes pour les
entreprises du cac 40 en 2021 et ils ont
licencié en france tranquille en trente
mille personnes donc là nous on n'est
pas pour ça par contre on est pour aider
toute seule qui produisent de l'emploi
et qui produisent des salaires voilà on
est pour des conditions dans les hes qui
a pas été fait par le gouvernement
oui la cobaci dort jamais le mélange
avant même le début annoncé que ça ne
servait à rien
et qu'il voulait des sanctions elle est
contrainte qu'elle contracte quelle
sanction bas que ça serve à rien on peut
chacun le constate et ensemble c'est à
dire que depuis la coop paris le gaz à
effet de serre continuent d'augmenter ça
la réalité mais désaccord sur 7 comme un
désaccord et en les emmenant
les accords ça a été des objectifs ou
donne des objectifs mais tant que vous
n'avez pas de contrainte étant qu'en
plus la cop16 devrait continuer à faire
vous vous instituez meubles droits à
polluer c'est à dire qui est un peu le
heures pour acheter le droit de polluer
ce qu'est que ce qui est est ce que
quand on regarde bien les choses est
absolument
hallucinant parquet le relais très
concrètement par exemple alors déjà une
première contrainte ça serait de
s'entendre pour que au niveau de l'onu
il y effectivement des normes qui oblige
les états à respecter justement les
objectifs que se donnent les coop on
pourrait imaginer tribune en aussi pour
une petite condamne pour écocide j'ai vu
que jean luc mélenchon c'est une bonne
idée proposer une espèce de casque vert
sert des gens qui pourraient des forces
d'intervention pour de l'onu pour aller
au pour aller au secours ou pour aller
pour aller intervenir sur sur des
situations de conséquence de
dérégulation du climat il ya plein de
choses à imaginer mais pour commencer il
faudrait que nous français nous fassions
parce que c'est bien gentil que emmanuel
macron de la leçon à tout le monde
extérieur mais le bilan français et
très mauvais bilan un bilan
catastrophique mois tout à l'heure je
vais présenter anton commissaires aux
finances mon cinquième rapport sur le
ministère de l'environnement et ses
opérateurs météo-france heerema est ce
que vous vous est ce que vous savez que
depuis cinq ans il ya moins 10000 postes
à peu près au niveau de ce ministère qui
devrait au sens de toutes nos
préoccupations et qui du coup se
retrouve avec les opérateurs dans
l'incapacité de 2,2 d'accomplir sa
mission ça c'est un exemple ou alors un
deuxième j'arrête là on nous dit à 30
milliards pour la pour l'investissement
écologique dans le dossier de presse du
plan de relance trop bien pour
l'investissement écologique
dans les faits on les trouve pas céder
effet d'annonce ou plutôt on se rend
compte qu'une partie de ces 30 milliards
c'est à l'aéronautique l'automobile etc
enfin tout ça est un non sens en vérité
nous mettons pas le paquet d'après lui
il faudrait 60 milliards
d'investissements plus est et au canada
quand même une dernière question sur la
france insoumise puisque bastien lachaud
député de la france insoumise de la
seine saint denis a été mis en examen
hier dans l' enquête sur le financement
de la campagne de 2007 de jouets en bon
livre enfin bon c'est pas grave
question mis en examen je cite un pur
prêt illicite de main d'oeuvre faux
escroquerie et tentative d'escroquerie
comment vous réagissez cette page réagi
je regarde les termes georges chrétien
doit regarder ça et se dire ah là là il
on a un responsable de france insoumise
à escroquer etc on se dit c'est terrible
ça sert à ça et quand on regarde dans
les faits on se rend compte que après
que les comptes ont été validés d'accord
on a des comptes ont été validés on se
retrouve à une enquête sur le long terme
et qu'à la fin du fin la seule chose qui
est reproché en réalité c'est le fait
que a été facturé comme dans n'importe
quelle société un salarié trois fois de
manière trois fois plus élevé que ce
qu'il a coûté en terme de salaire ce qui
s'appelle une marche pour les
entreprises qui s'appelle le fait de 2,2
m quand vous faites une facture va vous
mettez de manière normale dd ce qui ce
qui permet justement d'agir et pas
seulement le salary voilà ce qui est
reproché à bastia les choux
les valises à tous les comptes ont été
validés tous les comptes avaient été
validés simplement depuis quatre ans
n'est pas un épisode comme ça qu'ils
continuent et comme par hasard ces
quelques mois avant les élections où on
accuse un salarié de prêt illicite de
main d'oeuvre on l'accusé lui-même d'un
prêt illicite de main d'oeuvre où il
vient tout ça est absurde c'est à dire
qu'on se retrouve
a coûté moins cher que toutes celles de
nos concurrents les principaux moins
cher que toutes celles de concurrents
vinci ou par exemple on a respecté ce
que nous disent que nous demandaient les
comptes de campagne c'est-à-dire de
jamais sous facturés c'est ça qui est
qui recherchait donc on a toujours tenu
par
ceux qui trahissent cette campagne ont
toujours tenu à faire des prix qui sont
les prix du marché palau prix de journée
c'est les prix du marché dont donc et à
partir de là eh bien il n'y a pas de
fait une mise en examen ça repose sur
des faits quand même un eric coquerel
on mise en examen excusez-moi minuit
d'accord mais mais ça une mise en examen
des faits où on vous explique qu' on est
on estime que le salarié n'a pas été
assez payé par rapport à la journée
facturée ce qui est encore une fois le
pauvre salaire en gros c'était à x 2 x 3
par rapport à ça ce qu'ils pointent si
peu près tout les soutiers et qu'on
appelle ça escroquerie ce que noah s'est
pas d'effet c'est une manipulation de la
vérité et qui du coup évidemment a pour
objectif c'est de d'affaiblir la
campagne etc on connaît bien les choses
aller sur votre livre
très vite sans prendre assez aride non
oui on sent sirleaf qui dit une chose
c'est que on a augmenté considérablement
les déficits du fait de la crise que
vide voilà avant avant cette crise on
nous disait ah là là les déficits si la
dette c'est le plus gros problème du
pays bas vous rendez compte qu'on est à
+ 6 % de déficit est content c'est pas
ça le sujet principal est qu'il faut
l'effacer la santé moi je suis pour
annuler la dette qu'ovide terre la dette
qui est détenue aujourd'hui par la
banque de france pas par les marchés
donc c'est une écriture auscitain on
peut dire rapidement que c'est une
écriture monétaire qui est fait et qui
nous permettrait de ne pas payer comme
nous propose mails mâcon pendant cinq
ans ses dettes avec des politiques
d'austérité qui seront inédites merci
merci
[Musique]